well tonight's petersburg the last time
i've been on television with one of
these ladies this happened
tell me what i'd do i'd go and check out
some basic facts about your hero obama
he's not my hero
you didn't plan any protest against him
well i'm happy to still call myself an
idiot identify as an idiot did you still
identify as a commie all day every day
welcome back actually been a while and
julia lovely to see you julian brewer
here's a talk to you presented i want to
start with women because penny morgan
today has been coming under a bit of
flack for her views about women said two
things today which i suspect will ruffle
probably all the right feathers take a
look at these
i think it was margaret thatcher that
said that every prime minister needs a
willie
[Applause]
a woman like me
doesn't have one
a quick one on the straightforward one
how did you find a woman
i'm a woman i am biologically a woman
and i can tell you chris that if you
have been in the royal navy and you have
competed physically against men you
understand the biological difference
between men and women
well part of the fact that i loved her
campaign slogan pm for pm which has a
great ring to it um all right
you identify as a woman sometimes
always
you are a woman i am what is a woman to
you so for me a woman is someone who is
an adult who is human and is female and
female is both a biological category
where we're talking about biological sex
and a gender category so depending on
what we're talking about if you're
saying best female rapper no one's
checking chromosomes if you're talking
about female reproductive health you
know people aren't just talking about
your social life um it can be a
biological or a gender so when for
example the hot issue of the day when
you have trans women athletes who are
competing against women born to female
biological bodies do you think that's
fair do i think that's fair i think
you'd have to take a look at the whole
picture well leah thomas the swimmer for
example so it might be that in five to
ten years when you have much more uh
trans athletes breaking through and you
might see
cisgender women at a disadvantage you
have to go let's read let's rejig the
system in a way which can protect
women's sport and include trans people i
think right now because trans people
have been so marginalized so here's my
problem you're a smart young lady right
i follow you on twitter you're very
smart you you're very intellectually
rigorous about stuff
you know you know when you look at stuff
like leah thomas demolishing women in
the pool in america that this isn't fair
and you can support as i do and you do
trans rights to fairness and equality
and understand that on issues like sport
it is unfair but the thing that i'm
saying is that we haven't had a trans
olympic medalist yet female sports we've
had a trans
hang on we've had a trans weightlifter
in the new zealand olympics team
depriving a woman born to a female body
saying woman born to a female body well
okay fair enough there's only one kind
we're not a variant of women there's
only one kind of woman i'm not a cis
woman i'm not a woman born to i'm a
woman that's all i am i'm a woman right
and the other kind aren't women and i
guess my point fair enough and my point
about this i think would be that in that
case this weightlifter was unsuccessful
competing against men suddenly becomes
olympic standard as a woman and deprives
an actual woman of being able to get an
olympic place she was also unsuccessful
competing against women in the in the
olympia she did bad in the olympics but
she still got to the olympics she's an
olympian and yet as a man she never got
anywhere near it i just don't think that
there's enough evidence that women as a
sex are on mass being drummed out of
elite sport and the thing that i would
say they are though
that's just wrong we're seeing it in
sprinting we're seeing it in rugby we're
seeing it in cricket we're seeing it in
swimming we're seeing it everywhere as
there are more and more trans people
coming out as trans and i've got
absolute respect for that but there's
more and more people do you know in law
winston on last night who was who
couldn't have been clearer there is
biological sex and there is gender and
they are completely different things and
and look i'm not here to talk about you
know this is biological sex and this is
gender when it comes to the condition of
trans people in this country we know
that they're disproportionately excluded
from using athletic and healthcare
facilities we also know we don't yeah
they are but yeah
yeah because that's all we've got to go
on um but show that trans people
use gyms use athletics facilities at far
lower rates than cisgender people so i'd
say let's deal with that the other
things i'd say let's deal with is
look
the day-to-day problems trans people
face on about whether or not they can
compete in the olympics we're talking
about one in eight trans people report
being assaulted or abused at their place
of work by colleague or customer within
the last 12 months a quarter of all
trans people will experience
homelessness at some point in their
lives and i think that your audience so
why it's a white shirt right so your
audience at home emphasis that's
important and you're an empathetic
that's important to know and i hate to
hear that and i'm aware of that so why
choose the hill to go on
i want to have an unfair advantage over
women in sport why not just say we get
it that's unfair and bring people with
them as they move towards proper
fairness and equality no community is a
monolith all right no community is a
monolith and you're going to have some
trans people go for me the really
important thing is i want to participate
in sport that's going to be by its
definition because elites bought a
really small number okay the problem
okay i want to move on but the problem
is it is getting more and more people
julia let's talk about covid and novak
djokovic because i'll be going at it on
twitter right so i don't think you
should be that anywhere near the you the
uso because america if i want to go to
america which i will be quite soon i
have to take a test and show my
vaccination status that's it so does he
yeah so he shouldn't be allowed to play
right well he he has to abide by the
rules same well as everyone else
although interestingly in 2020 everyone
seemed quite happy for sportsmen and
women to have completely different rules
than the rest of us being able to travel
things like the australian open when
other people couldn't even get home to
see their families um yeah he's not
asking for special treatment though he
simply said i'm not vaccinated i'm not
showing my vaccine status and therefore
i can't play in the u.s open the point
is is this stupid rule your vaccine
protects you anyone who's taken a
vaccine it protects them we know with
omicron it doesn't actually provide much
protection at all from infection it does
protect you from getting seriously the
key point is it stops you from dying i
mean that's the whole point of the
vaccine piers
a young healthy man what is he in his
30s his chances of dying you're a young
healthy woman you've had this you've
been jabbed right i i have chosen to
disclose my jab status when i close the
disclosure
people talking about about transport
that's my business but whether one
chooses to actually show that at a
border you can choose this is the thing
you should be able to make a choice
bodily autonomy is the most fundamental
human right novak chocolate isn't asking
for special treatment i think it's
incredible he's standing by his
principles he's a young healthy man he
can physical fitness yeah he doesn't but
he's also a role model who will have
definitely deterred a lot of people who
perhaps should have the role models
sports people standing up for their
principles they're huge role models like
the england footballers who take a knee
for uh
but they'd happily go and uh compete in
the world cup in qatar where where we
have outrageous treatment of gay people
i've no problem with them taking minnie
i think it's good to say
in fact funny enough when the players
take the near arsenal when i go the
entire crowd of 60 000 people white
black and any type of they all cheer
i don't hear a single dissenting voice
but it's hypocrisy because you can't you
can't i can't do that and then go and
play ash this pack of lurpak has nearly
like doubled in price in the last few
months is that the 90s 335 now seven
now 489 so 50 or more rise right this is
indicative of what's going on with
prices everywhere we're choosing a new
prime minister
we can talk about all the culture war
stuff and i think a lot of it is
relevant and important actually for most
of our viewers
around the world cost of living cost of
butter and margarine and when you look
at the costs of heating on top of the
increase of the price of fuel the price
of food the price of rent everything
getting more expensive you know it's not
going up people's pe packets and in that
kind of context
what political party is standing up for
those people there's no major political
party in this country saying absolutely
everyone deserves uh matching inflation
pay rise so effectively people are being
told you're going to be made poorer deal
with it and i think there's only so long
a society can hold itself together under
those kinds of conditions julia richie's
soon favorite at the moment penny morden
making a march the problem is in a poll
that came out today
apparently at least two people who were
asked in the poll thought she was adele
let's take a look
she doesn't have much recognition we've
got a few seconds later there we are do
you think do you think she can beat
rishi i think she can i think it's all
to play for anyone making predictions
right now is probably a fool i think
their second preferences is going to be
where it all goes and that could all
change and as boris said he went today
with his head held high last thought
from you i'm making it quick this is a
man with a almost pathological lack of
self-awareness so i'm not supposed to
have gone with his head held in shame
that's it thank you to my panel actually
quite civilized come back i liked it
that's it from me whatever you're up to
keep it uncensored
you